ولمتابعه تطورات لحظه بلحظه في الشمال
السوريه نبقى مع شبكه مراسل العربيه
والصحفيين ايضا من على الارض من شمال ادلب
منير مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوريه انضموا الينا في هذا الجزء من
التغطيه مرحبا بك سيد منير نعلم انكم
تقومون بجهد كبير على الارض من خلال
الدفاع المدني السوري للتعامل مع هذه
الكارثه اخر الارقام واخر التطورات
في الحقيقه نحن دخلنا اليوم الخامس من
العمل متواصل منذ اللحظه الاولى يعني وقوع
هذا الزلزال المدمر في منطقه شمال غربي
سوريا وجنوب تركيا للاسف يعني في هذه
الساعات يعني في اخر 24 ساعه الماضيه لم
نعثر على احياء تحت الانقاض للاسف عداد
القتلى هو في ازدياد وعداد المصابين بات
يعني يتوقف تقريبا بشكل كامل طبعا معروف
عند كافه يعني الذي يعمل في موضوع الانقاذ
ان 72 ساعه الاولى من اي انهيار مثل هذا
او اي زلزال مثل هذا تكون هي الساعات
ذهبيه وهذا ما ناشد به فريق الفوز البيضاء
الدفاع المدني كل دول العالم للاصراع
لادخال مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا من اجل
السرعه في استخراج العالقين من تحت
الانقاض كلما طال الزمن كلما كان هناك
فرصه اقل في العثور على احياء تحت هذه
الانقاذ
انتم تعانون بالفعل في جهود الانقاذ لديكم
من نقص الاليات المتطوره من عدم وجود
معدات كافيه لعمليات الانقاذ
هذه حقيقه واقعه كانت موجوده في شمال غرب
سوريا فريق القوه البيضاء يتالف من 2800
يعني شخص عندهم معدات هندسيه ولكن لا تكفي
لمثل هكذا يعني استجابه نحن نتكلم عن اكثر
من 400 موقع في نفس اللحظه بحاجه الى تدخل
سريع وتدخل مباشر من فرق البحث والانقاذ
حتى تسحب العالقين من تحت الانقاب
الامكانات المتوفره بين يدي البيضاء من
معدات واليات غير قادره على ان تغطي كل
هذا العدد من عمليات الانقاذ في هذه
المناطق المتفرقه والبعيده بشكل او باخر
عن بعضها نوعا ما فلذلك ناشد الدفاع
المدني كل الدول للاسراع بادخال المساعدات
هذه الساعه بالخال الاليات بادخال المعدات
التقنيه التي تلزم اساسا لسحب العالقين من
تحت الانقاب صراحه كان هناك استنفار كامل
حتى على مستوى المدنيين الكثير من
المدنيين حاول تقديم ما لديه من معدات وما
لديه وضعها تحت يعني خدمه عفريق الخوذه
البيضاء من اجل مساهمه في سحب العالقين
وساعدتنا بشكل او باخر بسحب عدد من
العالقين ولكن للاسف قله الامكانيات وقله
الاليات كانت تحول دون الوصول الى بعض
المناطق بعض الاماكن التي تحتاج الى
عمليات البحث وهذا ما حاله الى زياده ساعد
في زياده عدد الوفيات بسبب تاخير وصول
المصابين الذين يتم نقلهم للعلاج هل كانت
تتوافر الخدمات الطبيه والامكانيات الطبيه
لانقاذ هؤلاء الجرحى ام انه كانت هناك
معاناه في هذه المساله
في الحقيقه ايضا هي معاناه اخرى في هذه
المساله يعني الزلزال يعني اتى على جزء من
المنظومه الصحيه والمشافي الموجوده في
منطقه شمال غرب سوريا وهي بالاساس يعني
بعد عشر سنين من الحرب كانت هي منهكه يعني
كان كان يعني قدرتها على استيعاب الطلب هي
قدره قدره يعني تقريبا بحدها الادنى
فعندما نقول
فعندما وقع هذا الزلزال فكيف عندما يكون
تدمر جزء من هذه المنظومه الصحيه تم جزء
من المشافي جزء من النقاط الطبيه وهناك
عدد هائل من المصابين وصل الى هذه
سيد منير
حقيقه كان هناك استنفار كامل في بعض
النقاط الطبيه التي لم يلحقها الضرر في
بعض المشاكل التي لم يلحقها الضرر الاطقم
الطبيه المتواجده حتى استعانوا في طلاب
الذين يدرسون طب بشري ولم يتخرجوا بعد
يعني السنه الخامسه ملتحقوا في المشافي
حتى يقدموا المساعدات حتى يقدموا
الاسعافات كان هناك استنفار كامل ولكن
الطاقه الاستيعابيه لم تكن يعني قادره على
استيعاب هذه الاعداد كان احيانا يعني تقدم
اسعافات اوليه لضمان حياه هذا الشخص الذي
وصل ثم يتم تخريجه من هذه يتم اخر
عن وضع الجرحى
في الحقيقه هناك تقارير تصدر تقريبا بشكل
يومي عن مديريات الصحه وعن المشافي بالوضع
الصحي للجرحى